PROFESSOR: So we've
discussed the extent
to which the size of a
droplet can influence
the infectivity or the
ability of a virion
to escape from that droplet
and, also, to be transmitted
to the deepest, smallest
passages in the lungs
as a function of its size.
There is also a dependence
on the relative humidity
of the air, which
is related to size.
And so, as we've seen,
humidity does vary the size,
but there's believed to be
also a more direct effect
of humidity, as I will
now try to explain.
So I'm relying here
on the recent work
of the group of Linsey
Marr, two papers cited here.
So we can distinguish
between two different types
of pathogens.
The first are the bacteria.
And here there's a
monotonic dependence
of the relative viability of
the pathogen, of the bacteria,
after a certain time period.
Let's say one hour.
And what is found is that,
above a certain threshold
of humidity, around
80% relative humidity,
that there's, essentially,
no change in the viability
of the bacteria.
They're alive.
They're infectious.
But, as the humidity,
relative humidity, is reduced,
then there's a significant
drop off in viability, which
depends on the specific
type of bacteria,
but it's a fairly general
trend that it comes down
significantly as you
approach more dry air.
Now what's happening is the size
of the droplets is shrinking.
In the case of the bacteria, we
can understand, to some extent,
why this dependence might be
here by thinking about solutes
that are present, especially
salts, in the system,
but, also, mucus--
mucosal proteins that
we've also discussed.
And, when the particles become
more dry, then what happens
is that the
concentration goes up,
and there's an increase
in the osmotic pressure
of the fluid around the
bacteria relative to the inside.
And, as with many
other kinds of cells,
when exposed to such
high osmotic pressures,
that can cause stress on the
cell and, potentially, even
rupturing of membranes or other
structures within the cell.
And, obviously, then it is
not good for the viability
of that cell and
leads to deactivation.
The case of viruses is
a bit more complicated.
So some old data of Harper from
the 1960s on the seasonal flu,
in particular, human
influenza virus A,
which was recently
analyzed by Marr's group,
showed that there was
a viral deactivation
rate that, essentially,
was scaling linearly
with the relative humidity.
So there's a faster deactivation
rate in more humid air,
less in dry air.
This is one way we can
understand the seasonal nature
of the flu in that, in more
dry, wintry environments,
especially away from--
in sort of the northern
or southern hemispheres,
we can expect that
then the virus
would be deactivating less.
But, of course, that's
compounded by the effect
that, in the winter, people
spend more time indoors,
and so that's also leading to
more seasonal transmission.
Now, if we convert
the deactivation rate
into relative viability
again, then we
see an interesting dependence
in recent experiments, which
were done using
bacteriophages, which
are models of different
kinds of human pathogens,
including the seasonal
flu and influenza viruses.
And, in particular, there's
a non-monotonic dependence
where, essentially, there's a
maximum rate of deactivation
around the range of 70% or
80% humidity, or 60% to 80%.
And, similarly, the viability
was the lowest in that range.
And the way the authors
proposed to explain
that was a hypothesis that there
are solutes that are present,
which may be, for
example, sodium
chloride or, in particular,
chloride ions, perhaps, that,
when we reach the higher
concentration in the shrunken
droplets, that there is,
again, a stress on the virus,
but, in this case, regardless
of the details of the mechanism
of deactivation for these
encapsulated viruses,
the idea is that
the cumulative dose
or exposure of those
solutes is what's important.
So, if the shrinking
happens very fast,
and we end up with a
droplet nucleus of, mostly,
bound water, and it happens
over a short period of time,
the exposure to those
solutes is limited.
And, hence, we end up with high
viability, low deactivation
rate in dry conditions.
Conversely, in very
humid conditions,
the droplets stay big.
In fact, they may
even grow because
of the hygroscopic solutes.
And, in that case, there's
plenty of solutes present,
but they're very dilute.
And so, again, the effect
on the virus is minimal.
And the greatest deactivation
and, also, the maximum--
the sort of minimum
viability is actually
at an intermediate
range of humidities.
So this tells you
that maintaining
a comfortable humidity in
the range of 50% to 80%
may, actually, be the best
for minimizing the viability
of viral pathogens.